more democratic leaders are peeling back
coveted mandates los angeles county is
lifting its outdoor mask mandate today
well that's a good thing after that rams
win which was fabulous by the way the
game in total was great but all the the
you know the mayor holding his breath
the whole time because he didn't have on
a mass so it's a good thing it's
outdoors to say for them now uh the
state of california is one of four blue
states which no longer
have indoor mass mandates but are
keeping the schools massed up while five
other democratic-led states have opted
to let children come to school without
wearing their masks it's the choice of
the parents and despite a lot of
criticism that these decisions are
political
dr anthony fauci weighed in
do you think that the local politics
when it comes to these kinds of mandates
are overriding the science or largely no
well
hallie i wouldn't say it's the politics
i think it's it's it's the different
evaluation of what's right for a
particular community i mean you were you
use the word politics i'm not so sure
it's that i just think at the local
level
there's a strong feeling of needing to
get back to
normality jimmy fayla is host of fox
across america on fox news radio dr
fouch he could have just said you know
what politics not my lane let me tell
you about the science he never says that
though but it is his lane that's why
he's discredited himself so much like at
this point we should replace fauchi with
something americans trust more like the
sushi at a gas station nobody takes this
guy seriously harris which can be
delicious
it's touch and go you know what i mean
you got to know where the station is can
be delicious but you know you look at
polling that says 31 of americans don't
take this guy seriously they don't take
his health initiative seriously if you
were running an nfl team and 69 percent
of the players weren't going to run the
play that came into the huddle there's
no way you're going to win that game
which is why fauci has lost the locker
room and has to go but as it pertains to
the mass mandates okay democratic
leaders are jumping into political
lifeboats because they know the kovid
regime is sinking and they want to get
off so but this is a good thing for
those communities the thing that i don't
understand is the science points to
taking the mask off the children first
just because of the percentage of them
who've already had it and the percentage
of them who don't suffer mightily from
it when they get it particularly with
omicron letting them choose things like
mental health and those issues
first and then
feathering in the adults well that's
what's so infuriating about this is they
would accuse us of being cavalier with
children health if we wanted to unmask
them but in truth masking them is being
cavalier with their of course it is okay
think of where we are to the points you
just made okay the cdc flat out tells us
that a cloth mask does not work against
omicron says it so right then and there
full stop the mask comes off masking
kids is child abuse and it's sickening
to me that with all this good point you
know because most people are never going
to put their child in a in an in 95 not
a k 95 but those like really ones that
leave all the divots on your face and
all that they're saying well those are
the ones that really work well have you
had one show up at your house yet
because they said they're sending five
numbers well they're coming from china
there's a little bit of a shipping delay
uh it's not the money
but it drives me crazy because like you
know right now without any data to
support it kids all over the country are
sitting in a classroom with a mask on
maybe not my kid he's probably cutting
but seriously this is true do you
remember the motley crue song smoking in
the boys room it's now a meanness it's
now mask-less in the boys room kids go
to the boys room lincoln told me this to
take off their masks and be rogue for
five minutes that's ridiculous and
lincoln by the way is this beautiful
baby he's a good kid but the name
lincoln is a little controversial now so
he has to go by his middle name oj
you never let up
okay president biden is sharing a very
bizarre anecdote from his time in local
government and this just happened let's
watch
i got a call one night
a woman said to me obviously not in the
same persuasion as i was politically
called me and said there's a dead dog on
my lawn and i said well i'll get him in
the morning she said i want it removed
now i pay your salary
so i went over it
i picked it up
she said i want it out of my front yard
i put it on her doorstep
[Laughter]
[Applause]
jimmy stop it first of all if it was
true dead dog removal would be the one
thing he lowered the cost of so
congratulations pardon you finally did
it but we don't think this is true it's
like one of those other made-up stories
that he was a truck driver or he knew
the guy on amtrak this is the stupidest
thing
so politically gosh i hope i'm not
becoming more of a cynic but this is
what i
really thought at first because our
politics are so toxic right now i
thought is he flexing politically so he
can appear like a bad boy to the
republicans like look what i did to the
republican caller in the middle of the
night i went to that lady's house which
is so inappropriate it's like following
kirsten cinema into the bathroom because
you don't agree with her politics
moderate democrat there i don't think
he's that strategic i actually think i
do i actually think he just likes dogs
in general like they just adopt them he
does like dogs he likes having someone
in the white house that makes deals
under the table besides hunter it means
a lot to him good night everybody wow
okay i think that's my only wildest hour
i'm trying to cut back on the wow
jimmy fella thank you the best hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now